hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residence this is the
spring 2016 edition in this edition are
articles on satellite broadband a six
rivers funding free crime prevention
advice advice on after prom parties the
may 2016 elections a special farewell
from the chairman and much more but
we'll start with details of a very
special award to a very special local
venue Raley windmill has always offered
something different as a venue for
anyone getting married now that status
has been recognized with the historic
building winning the essex wedding
awards title wedding venue of the year
something different at the glamorous
gala event on thursday 26th of november
2015 the judges commented on the night
small but beautifully put together
judges felt that the rayleigh windmill
really was something different they
especially liked how they offered a
dedicated event coordinator working
nonstop for every couple along with the
beautiful grounds for excellent photo
opportunities the beautiful Raley
windmill is a grade two listed building
more than 200 years old and has been
sympathetically refurbished and restored
to its original grandeur to offer a
completely unique venue for weddings
built in 1812 the windmill is an
important and iconic landmark in the
town and district the striking white
sails can be seen from far and wide
standing at just over 20 meters it is
the tallest windmill in Essex many of
the couples who've choose to get married
at the windmill are looking to make
their special day a relaxed and intimate
occasion for close family and friends
with seating for up to 20 guests rarely
windmill is a venue that offers exactly
that in the run-up to reaching the 200
mile stone the council ran the
competition offering any couples who
booked the windmill a 10-percent
discount on their higher fee with the
lucky 200th couple winning the
prestigious landmark higher free of
charge Raila when mill has
eating for up to 20 guests and is a
suitable venue for all civil ceremonies
and is situated next to a stunning
sensory garden and the historic Raley
mount a perfect backdrop for your
pictures you also have a dedicated event
coordinator who will ensure that your
special day runs perfectly and is
everything you want it to be Raley also
has a host of venues for your reception
including the mill Arts & Events Center
adjacent to the windmill in addition it
boasts many bespoke services and
businesses to help make your day extra
special including florists jeweler's
formal wedding attire and decorations
for more information or to book your
ceremony please contact 0170 2318 120
their website is www a govt UK forward
slash weddings and for further
photographs please visit
www.buyhomewithoptions.com at a capped
cost for the first year the scheme forms
part of the national broadband delivery
UK or b d UK program being led by UK
government and delivers on the
commitment to ensure those not currently
due to benefit from a fiber upgrade can
access download speeds of at least two
megabytes per second so far the
superfast essex fibre rollout has
reached 60,000 homes and businesses the
halfway milestone in the overall program
roll out and just 5,000 away from the
total set to be reached by the end of
the first phase of work this summer the
scheme is available to Essex homes or
businesses provided that their property
currently receives broadband speeds of
less than 2 megabytes per second is
unable to access broadband speeds of 2
megabytes per second or above from any
other broadband supplier in the area is
not in the plan to be upgraded by the
superfast Essex fibre rollout within six
months of the date of application
residents and businesses can find out
more and submit an application by
completing the short online form
available at WWDC org forward slash
satellite growth hub helps grow
businesses whether you want to start a
new business grow an existing business
or find funding for a new venture the
best growth hub team is here to help you
we have an enthusiastic team of business
navigators who are able to meet you at
your premises to discuss your business
needs and identify ways that we can help
your business grow the best growth hub
also provides a new website which
contains free business support listings
the opportunity to search for grants and
finance in your area an up to date list
of events for business news and current
information as well as an essex
procurement portal that enables you to
find contract opportunities in your area
best of all best growth hub services are
fully funded for businesses located
within Essex so it won't cost you a
penny for example starting a business
thinking of starting up your own
business as a start-up in Essex you
could be eligible for a grant or a loan
to help finance your new business and
see it flourish as well as gain access
to knowledge and advice
growing a business if your business is
established the next step is to grow
best can help you and your team to
expand your capacity knowledge and
expertise if you're looking to grow your
business our navigators access the
support and advice you need and
financing a business if you need
external financial support there are
currently a number of grants and finance
opportunities available to help you
start or grow your business contact us
today to find out more and for more
information speak to one of our business
navigators today on 0170 241 7765 or
visit www best grove hub org UK to
register your details essex rivers
leader funding essex rivers has launched
its new funding program for rural
businesses small businesses farmers
foresters and community groups from the
rural areas of Rochford braintree
brentwood Chelmsford Colchester and
morden can now apply to access 1.8
million pounds of funding secured
through Defra and the EU the aim of the
funding is to create jobs and promote
business growth in rural areas it will
focus on projects covering small
business growth farm diversification
rural tourism the provision of rural
services cultural and heritage
activities and farm or forest woodland
productivity for more information visit
www k or contact the program team
beverly davies program manager or Neil
Harper Program Officer RCC a hyphen
Essex rivers telephone oh 1 376 574
double 30 email info at Essex rivers co
uk budget consultation in the recent
budget consultation residents were asked
to identify the council services
that they're considered to be very
important the top three are number one
waste and recycling number two
safeguarding and community safety and
number three street cleansing residents
were also asked to state which services
were not important to them that top 31
leisure services to public conveniences
3 accommodation for the homeless when it
came to identifying ways to make savings
or generating income a number of ideas
were put forward these included review
existing contracts collaboratively with
other councils and make greater use of
renewable energy sources a number of
residents also stated that they are
interested in helping to manage and run
local services the budget survey asking
residents to prioritize council services
was published in the last edition of
Rochford district matters and made
available online on the council website
copies of the survey were also available
at local libraries and distributed at
council meetings and events in order to
get as many responses as possible the
feedback from this consultation was
considered by members during the budget
process if you answered the budget
survey or if you want to help shape and
inform policy in the future why not join
our have your say group the group is
made up of Rochford residents who
volunteer to express their views on the
council's proposals and local services
the information you provide helps the
council to make its decisions in order
for us to get the information we need
you will be asked to fill in
questionnaires and participate in focus
groups when signing up you'll be asked
to highlight any particular areas of
interest to ensure
your views are taken into account when
relevant consultations come up you can
sign up at the group at WWF a govt UK /h
why s sign up and that's all one word or
you could phone the Community Planning
Office on 0170 23 1806 one you can email
Community Planning at Rochford dot-gov
dot uk' Rochford district matters update
as people are now consuming news online
and looking for information via websites
and social media rochford District
Council has decided to publish ongoing
news on the council's website at www k
if for some reason you don't have access
to the internet you can contact us at
Rochford district council communications
south street rochford essex SS for one
BW Roger district council is at the
early stages of reviewing its policies
which are used to determine planning
applications the statement of community
involvement is a planning document which
sets out how we will involve the
community in plan making and the
consideration of planning applications
as part of the wider review of planning
policies the statement of community
involvement is being updated to ensure
our practices remain of the highest
standard and are up to date with
national planning guidance this document
will be publicly consulted on in due
course if you'd like to be kept
up-to-date on future planning policy
consultations and opportunities to be
involved in plan making please join the
planning policy teams mailing list in
one of the following ways online w WH
foods ad I consult net and follow the
links by post planning policy
see rochford district council council
offices south street rockford essex SS
for one BW or by telephone 0170 23 1819
one paper copies will also be available
in rockford and rayleigh receptions area
and in libraries during normal opening
hours free crime prevention advice for
residents and businesses although a
burglary represents a small percentage
of overall crime in the district its
impact on the individuals involved is
nevertheless significant both
financially and emotionally you can use
the following steps to help make a big
difference to keeping your property safe
from burglary lock your doors and
windows every time you leave the house
even when you're just out in the garden
remembering to double lock upvc doors
lift the handle and turn the key hide
all keys including car keys out of sight
away from the letterbox remember a
device could be used to hook keys
through the letterbox install a visual
burglar alarm install good outside
lighting get a trusted neighbor to keep
an eye on your property leave radios or
lights in your house on a timer to make
the property appear occupied make sure
the fences around your garden are in
good condition secure bikes at home by
locking them to an immovable object
inside a locked shed or garage keep
ladders and tools stored away don't
leave them outside where they could be
used to break into your home ensure side
gates are locked to prevent access to
the rear of the property and ensure rear
fencing is in good repair improve
natural surveillance at the front of
your property I trim high hedges make
mark your property with postcode and
house number and register your property
for free with immobilized @wwe mobilize
calm consider joining or forming a
neighbourhood watch scheme for contact
details see w WR r NW govt
c om is dead a calm or ring o 1268
double 705 19 remove valuables from view
of ground-floor windows store any
high-value items IE jewelry or passports
in a properly secured safe or bank vault
this information was taken from the
police UK website for more information
go to ww police UK and forwarded the
links you can't beat accurate and
up-to-date advice from Essex Police
Crime Prevention tactical advisors who
operate across essex Mr Clarke is the
advisor for Rochford and Castle Point
and she can give advice on how to keep
your home or business safe so give her a
call or email on crime prevention
technical advisers at Essex dot pnn
police UK or phone 101 extension for 905
double three protect your property with
smart water the Rockford district
Community Safety Partnership or the CSP
works towards reducing crime and the
number of victims of crime to help
tackle dwelling burglary we're giving
away property marking kits in areas most
recently affected by this offence a
proven deterrent to burglars SmartWater
forensic marking system enables you to
safely mark up to 50 items of property
with traceable liquid which is then
exclusively registered property marked
in this way you can then be traced back
to the loser in the event of it being
stolen and recovered by the police
further details about the system can be
found at ww are water calm the product
is commercially available and retails at
approximately 60 pounds but is being
offered in the target area
years free of charge by the Community
Safety Partnership to help prevent you
from being a victim of crime police
community support officers or accredited
volunteers will call to deliver the
product and give you simple instructions
on how to apply it to your property if
you're interested in taking up this
offer please contact the community
safety team at Rockford District Council
on 0 1 702 3 1810 3 or by email
Community Safety at Rochford gov dot uk'
if your home isn't in a target area but
is within the district we're able to
offer the kids for a small charge new
Rochford district ward patents the
independent local government boundary
commission for England has completed its
electoral review of Rochford District
Council an electoral review examines and
proposes new electoral arrangements for
a local authority covering the total
number of councillors representing the
council's voters the council size the
names number and boundaries of wards or
electoral divisions the number of
councillors representing each ward or
division the Rockford electoral changes
order 2015 to implement recommendations
made by the Boundary Commission for new
boundaries was passed in parliament on
the 6th of November 2015 and will come
into force at the may 2016 local
elections the new district Ward patterns
for Rochford consists of 13 wards each
represented by three district ward
councillors the uniform three-member
Ward approach addresses electoral
equality so that each district
councillor represents approximately the
same number of voters and each elector
has the same opportunity to vote in
local elections each time they're held
there is a map that provides an overview
of how the electoral arrangements look
together with the new Ward names and the
following council
webpage will enable you to check online
where your road sits within the new
boundaries and that's at ww our govt UK
/ polling district review more details
are available at the council's webpage
and this also provides links to the
boundary Commission's official website
which is www k / electoral review
election alarm clock the election alarm
clock is a convenient way to keep up to
date with all the information regarding
upcoming elections by signing up to the
election alarm clock you will be alerted
to upcoming elections when and how to
register for elections when and how you
can vote and where you can vote to sign
up for this service visit w WR a govt UK
/ election alarm clock fill in your
details as requested and click Submit
that's it once you have done this you'll
start to receive election alerts may
2016 elections elections to all 39 seats
on Rochford district council will take
place on the fifth of may 2016 these
elections will be combined with the
election of a police and crime
commissioner for essex and the parish
and town council elections of hockley
hullbridge and rayleigh farewell from
the Chairman I have been honored to be
the chairman of Rochford district
council since May 2015 during this time
so many groups schools clubs parishes
and individuals have welcomed me into
their communities and it has been
amazing to see how many caring and
talented people we have in the Rockford
district many of whom work voluntarily
to help those around them as we build
new homes I hope that you will welcome
the new people moving into our community
is as much as you have welcomed me I've
also been invited to events around Essex
and London where I have endeavored to
promote the tourism that we are creating
in the Rockford area attractions
including rspb wallasey Island foul ness
Rochford Hall home of anberlin hockley
woods hullbridge with the boats and
River Crouch Raley windmill amongst many
others these are such interesting areas
and I hope that the many people i have
met will now come and visit our district
the end of my term of officers chairman
also marks the conclusion of my time as
a district councillor after a total
period of 26 years I would like to thank
everybody I have met and worked with
during this time and urge you to
continue making the Rochford district
such a special and welcoming place Thank
You Heather counselor Heather Glynn
chairman of Rochford District Council
may 2015 to 16 young people of the Year
awards children from all over Essex were
rewarded for their special achievements
at the young people of the Year awards
during a ceremony held at the queen mary
university in london the highlight of
the afternoon was when 16 year old
George Hughes who lives in rochford and
attends the King Edmund school was
presented with the most prestigious
award Essex's young person of the year
George had always been regarded as a
naughty boy struggling to fit in at
school because of his challenging
behavior but at the age of 11 his
diagnosis as being on the autistic
spectrum changed his life five years
later he has developed into a mature
caring and trustworthy young man and his
thriving in the roles of specialist
prefect and special needs ambassador for
his school adamant that no other child
should go through what he had
experienced George said
I support younger special needs children
to help them adjust to high school life
some of their needs are social some
physical and some are not visible to
others I understand their needs as I too
have previously known their troubles I'm
very happy right now and my advice to
other young people would be to never
give up and to always try your hardest
the High Sheriff of Essex Vincent
Thompson who presented the award said
that the 16 year old has achieved a
great deal to become an advocate for
those with similar problems George had
been shortlisted out of hundreds of
entries from across essex which were
judged by a 50-strong panel that
included many mayors and council
chairman plus young people who have
taken part in previous ceremonies the
chairman of roxford district council
counselor mrs. Heather Glynn was on the
judging panel she said I was honored to
be present when George Hughes received
his award particularly because the King
Edmund school is within the area I have
represented for more than a quarter of a
century congratulations to George and to
all of the students at the King Edmund
school information about the awards and
all of the shortlisted candidates is
available at wwu people of the year org
after prom parties advice for attendees
vehicles for hire the law requires all
such vehicles to be properly licensed
and not carrying more than eight
passengers whatever the size of the
vehicle for the safety of the passengers
before booking or hiring operators
should be asked if they are licensed and
if so what type of license they hold
there are two types of license which
these vehicles may have one a restricted
passenger carrying Vehicles license also
known as public service vehicle license
the driver requires only an ordinary
driving licence and does not need to be
medically checked or criminal record
checked to a private hire vehicle
license both vehicle and driver required
to be properly licensed
the driver is medically checked to group
to standard and his criminal record
checked many of these vehicles being
offered for hire are unlicensed and as
such are not subject to mechanical
inspection or any other checks on their
proprietors or drivers novelty vehicles
are becoming increasingly popular tanks
jeeps fire engines trikes motorcycles
plant hire vehicles from building sites
and other unusual vehicles all making
appearances at prom nights carrying
students these vehicles if being used
for hire and reward are required to be
nice instead of them would not be
licensed on safety grounds if not
licensed they will not be covered by the
correct hire and reward insurance to
check if a vehicle is licensed contact
your local authority licensing
department for vehicles of eight
passengers or under and vos a for all
other vehicles on oh one double 2 3 53
10 45 or a 870 60 60 double 40 personal
safety please ensure you have arranged
to get home safely street lights may not
be lit and in rural areas there may be
no pavements on narrow fast roads leave
the area quietly residents do not want
to be disturbed by shouting or vandalism
to their property taxi availability is
limited late at night you may have to
wait in bad weather or unlit areas to be
picked up alcohol it's illegal for
alcohol to be sold or supplied to minors
also for under-18s to consume alcohol
advice for organizers as the event
organizer you would be responsible for
the entire running of the event in
addition to this you need to take
greater consideration as the majority of
those attending will be under 18 years
of age the legislation regarding the
supervision of children must be covered
venues a number of organizers have hired
fields or farms believing that the event
not cause a disturbance to the local
residents however other factors must be
taken into consideration such as the
safety of the attendees leaving the
venue public transport access street
lighting and how the event will impact
on the local highways licensing you will
need a check of the venue holds the
license for regulated entertainment
mainly the DJ or live band if the venue
has a premises licence ask to see a copy
as the license will have a number of
conditions if the venue does not hold a
licence you will need to apply for a
temporary event notice from the local
council licensing department that is a
licensing at Rochford govt UK as the
event organiser you will need to have
insurance to cover any incidents at your
event we would recommend you hold public
liability insurance for a minimum of 5
million pounds if you don't have a
temporary event notice and carry out an
activity that you should hold a light
since 4 or allow your premises pit to be
used for one you can be fined sent to
prison for up to six months or both
security and the no circumstances should
a parent or member of the public guests
coming into the event searching must be
carried out by persons who are security
industry authority SI a approved licence
holders they will be responsible for any
confiscations which take place ratio of
children to adults the advice from the
NSPCC states there should be one
responsible adult to every ten children
between the ages of 13 to 18 a
responsible adult would be considered
someone that will be on site to assist
the organiser this figure should not
include those conducting other roles ie
security first aid DJ etc first aid
cover and toilet facilities you will be
responsible for arranging first aid
cover and toilet facilities throughout
the event please refer to the health and
safety guide for event management to
determine the correct number of first
aid resources and toilets you will need
on site if you have any queries please
do not hesitate to contact your local
authority license licensing department
licensing at Rochford got you k or the
police licensing team many ways to reuse
and recycle the council have provided a
number of recycling banks all over the
district to make it even easier to
recycle you can take extra recycling to
any of these sites if you have too much
to fit into your gray wheelie bin or you
can use them when you're out and about
for cans and bottles etc there are quite
a number of banks where textiles can be
recycled please place any reusable
clothing and textiles in bags and place
them in the banks or alternatively you
can use the curbside textile reuse
scheme run by essex textiles please
contact them on Oh 800 787 9071 for
further information Essex textiles
provide blue bags for your clothing and
textiles which can be placed out next to
your bins on your recycling collection
day please ensure that clothing and
textiles are not placed in the
recyclables bin there are also a couple
of banks in the district where old and
broken small electrical items can be
recycled these banks which are in back
lane Rochford and paul's lane hullbridge
you'd put them actually into the one
that's marked essex textiles back there
can accept small electrical items such
as hair dryers electric toothbrushes
toasters and kettles however larger
electrical items such as fridges washing
machines and televisions cannot be
accepted here if you have any large
electrical items and they're in a
reusable condition they can be collected
free of charge from your property by the
hope works
Youth Center they can be contacted on 01
2687 four 32 32 they also collect
reusable furniture and other household
items if you have any large items that
cannot be reused then you can contact
the council to arrange a bulky waste
collection or you can take them to the
household recycling center in Castle
Road rayleigh community cached benefit
all charities and community groups have
been rewarded for their hard work with
funding from Rochford District Council
every year the council hands out cash to
support voluntary organisations across
the district June Lumley Rochford
district councillor and chairman of
rayleigh Rochford and district
association for voluntary services said
i am always amazed the wonderful work
volunteers and community organizations
undertake across the whole district
these groups make a huge difference to
our residents quality of life and that
of our young people who are growing up
in an ever-changing world geographically
the whole Rochford district from Great
Wakering to rayleigh benefits and
demographically residents young and old
are represented from skout tents to LED
lighting for the bar and bus trust which
specializes in outreach support for
young people to dementia training for
carers the funds are going to benefit so
many people Kara's choices based in
Coombe road benfleet was given 1414
pounds to help with its work Angela
album from the scheme said the money
will pay for courses to help people
caring for people with dementia she said
we are overwhelmed with gratitude for
this grant it'll mean so much to the
carers of those living with dementia the
money will pay for free dementia
awareness virtual dementia tours these
are two and a half hour courses for
carers to give them a real understanding
of what it is like to have dementia most
alum added the grant means we can hire a
specialist company to come and provide
the training
because of the very nature of being a
carer just getting here is a mammoth
task as they have to get their loved
ones looked after what the grant will
also do is to ensure that no carer has
to pay for this and that transport will
be provided roxford district can be very
rural and this can heighten people's
feelings of isolation we will be getting
the message out there and we will ensure
that all Rochford district residents are
made aware and those who are affected by
dementia get the chance to book a place
people affected by domestic abuse will
get a helping hand from a 1,000 pound
grant watch for District Council gave
the cash to basildon women's aid for its
specialist services for people affected
by domestic abuse in and around the
district including counseling community
based outreach services and practical
and emotional support chief executive
Jessica Barclay Lambert said it's
important to highlight the partnership
working between us and Rockford Council
we're very grateful to Rochford cancel
for this grant and their ongoing support
that allows us to continue to provide
these essential server to all who need
them rochford scouts will be able to
extend their heart with thanks to a
1,500 pound hand out the fourth Rochford
scout group were given the money towards
an extension to the Scout Hall and the
first Raley scout group were given 800
pounds to buy four new tents bill near
barred of the fourth Rochford scout
group said we like many others in the
Rockford district council area are
successful and well subscribed having a
youth membership of over a hundred
including wheelchair using membership we
provide opportunities for all children
aged 5 to 14 years to make friends build
confidence and independence and to
become good citizens it is our aim to be
fully inclusive and offer opportunities
that raise aspirations for all children
regardless of their physical or
cognitive abilities rochford District
Council gave 500 pounds to the Great
White Queen summer place team held in
the Great Wakering community center the
sessions will run between Monday August
the eighth and Friday August the 12th
from ten a.m. to 1230pm the events are
open to all children up to the age of 11
and there is an under fives room which
gives a more protected play area for
smaller children Kevin steep odds of the
Great Wakering summer place scheme said
this is a not-for-profit event run by
unpaid volunteers and the entrance fee
is kept as low as possible to ensure
that it can be accessible to as many
families as possible however in recent
years it has struggled financially and
has made losses therefore the receipt of
the grant from Rochford District Council
is vitally important as this funding
ensures the continuance of the event in
recent years more than 500 children have
registered to attend each event where
they can come for one or more days or
the whole week castlepoint association
of voluntary services was given 1000
pounds to continue its befriending
scheme in both Castle Point and Rockford
befrienders are people of all ages and
from all walks of life that have offered
their time on a voluntary basis they are
paired with someone who is experiencing
social isolation taking into account
their interests and hobbies in order
that they have more common ground on
which to build a rapport the aim of the
service is to provide companionship and
emotional support to the residents of
Castle Point and Rockford a spokesman
from Cavs befriending service said Cavs
is extremely pleased to receive this
funding and thanks Rochford district
their contribution to the pre friending
steam the grant will provide support
towards the service offered in the
Rockford district for isolated
individuals who would benefit from
having increased companionship southend
achievement through four was awarded
1350 pounds towards the cost of
providing a trained a
I a football coach and buying new
football kit and equipment Stewart long
spokesman for the Rockford branch said
the grant is fantastic news for us and
the young people of Rochford our weekly
sessions in Rockford and Wakering
provide the young people with a base and
security and an alternative to getting
into trouble we operate from public
areas which have been prone to
antisocial behavior and therefore even
where we cannot directly engage with all
the young people we can be the eyes and
ears for the community and all the other
awards rarely Rochford and district
association of the voluntary service
received 15,000 pounds as a
district-wide organization active
rockford and Crouch Valley Scouts were
awarded a thousand pounds age old
people's welfare committee for Rochford
district received 1,500 pounds towards
new chairs for the day Center hullbridge
senior citizens welfare council received
a thousand pounds for a new carpet great
white queen thirsty club received 476
pounds for blackout roller blinds at the
Great Wakering Methodist Church Rochford
district schools partnership received
one thousand three hundred pound for the
supply of educational psychologists and
senior family support worker and to buy
books and DVDs to lend to families the
RA RDSP helps disabled children and
their families equal people performing
arts one thousand four hundred and sixty
pounds towards the purchase of six
conference tables and a projector in the
rayleigh district rochford bowling club
1500 pounds towards the cost of
maintaining of greens Raley football
club was awarded 600 pounds to buy a
defibrillator footprints community group
a young people's group in Rockford 600
pounds for a ten session martial arts
course the bar and bus trust part of the
rayleigh young people outreach support
500-pound towards the cost of patio
chairs LED lighting and a projector
raley age concern at the Taubman center
received 1,500 pounds to replace
existing toilets and the disabled toilet
at raley communities unite to
commemorate the Holocaust crowds
gathered by the memorial to victims of
persecution in bellingham Lane Rayleigh
for a special service to commemorate
National Holocaust Memorial Day led by
the chairman of Rochford District
Council Councillor Heather Glynn and her
chaplain the Reverend Alan heard and
attended by the Lord Lieutenant of Essex
Lord Peter the High Sheriff of Essex
Vincent Thompson the chairman of Essex
County Council Councillor Norman Hume as
well as dozens of members of the public
the service was a poignant reminder of
the atrocities of the Holocaust and all
subsequent genocides arethe was laid by
representatives from the Royal British
Legion and the service concluded with a
statement of commitment to prevent all
forms of victimization and genocide read
by students from the district's
secondary schools and a blessing from
the right reverend john raw the area
bishop of Bradwell the service was
followed by a special reception inside
the mill arts and event center featuring
a sad yet inspirational talk from auto
deutsch about how he survived the
Holocaust when he was sent away from his
family as a young child on a
kindergarten train to England it's also
an informative presentation by year 13
students from the Swain park school
Megan Miller and Hannah esculent on
their lessons from our switch project
the chairman of Rochford District
Council Councillor mrs. Heather Glynn
said I would like to thank all of the
people involved in the organization of
this afternoon's event especially jack
de Metz from the south end and westcliff
hebrew congregation and
deutsch whose story has been very
humbling thanks to to all of the
secondary school children who took part
particularly from Swain those from Swain
Park who delivered an exceptional
presentation having representatives from
so many different religious groups ages
and backgrounds together in one place to
mark this important day is a positive
step in working towards a safe society
that is respectful of everyone hockley
art trail 2016 that's from saturday the
second to saturday the 9th of july
hotlist 2015 art trail was a great
success for artists venues and residents
and following requests from everyone
involved the Parish Council has been
asked to extend the event this year the
art trail will be held over eight days
between the second and the ninth of July
will be spread spread across
approximately 30 shops and businesses in
hockley town center the trail showcases
a variety of artwork by local artists
and art groups and is likely to include
paintings photography ceramics glass
work sculptures and jewelry the entry
fee for artists will be 5 pounds to
cover administration costs and is free
for the viewing public further details
can be obtained from hockley parish
councillors Tim glad all on 0 1 702 2016
8 8 Veronica Randall 0170 to 20 to 1 42
or sue Martin 0170 to 20 to 750 on
saturday the twenty-fifth of june
there's an event at ashington primary
academy from 12 noon to five PM the
admission is free
the community joins together to
celebrate a thousand years on from the
Battle of ashington there will be a
reenactment of the Battle traditional
stalls food and lots of family
activities brought to you by ashington
primary academy and ashington Parish
Council Macmillan GP appointed to
provide specialist cancer support in
Castle Point and Rockford a local GP is
set to dedicate one day a week to
improving cancer services in Castle
Point and Rochford becoming the
Macmillan GP for that area in a new role
funded by macmillan cancer support dr.
Peter long will work with NHS castle
point and Rochford clinical
commissioning group known as ccg over
the next two years to identify areas for
improvement which could include early
diagnosis and more supported care in the
community as well as continuing his day
job as a GP at rock bottom Lane benfleet
dr. long will now spend one day each
week working alongside local GPs to
enhance their knowledge and skills
around the delivery of services for
patients with cancer drawing on his
experience from working with people with
cancer in general practice doctor long
aims to improve early diagnosis and
communication between GPS and hospitals
to ensure early intervention and the
best follow-up care is provided dr. long
new Macmillan GP lead for castle point
and Rochford ccg said this role offers
an opportunity to improve services for
local patients and families experiencing
the difficult period that a cancer
diagnosis can bring my efforts will be
to improve links between GPS and
hospitals and to promote further
resources available in Castle Point and
Rochford instead stern accountable
officer at NHS castle point and Rochford
ccg which successfully bid to bring the
Macmillan GP to the area said we're
really looking forward to working with
dr. lung and macmillan cancer support to
improve cancer services for people in
Castle Point in Rockford this is a great
opportunity
to make the most of the partnerships we
have been busy creating as part of our
aim to Commission joined up high quality
care for local people the environment
waste not want not and I might tell you
that this article is accompanied by
pictures of all kinds of rubbish some of
it is quite horrendous ladies knickers
dirty nappies last week's take away
remains a Christmas Santa figure a
breadboard and a rolling pin these are
just some of the items that were
retrieved by staff at the depot sorting
out rochford district councils
recyclables waste that's right
recyclables the fact is that recycled
waste like that can't be recycled at all
and that means that more goes into
landfill and for residents more cost
residents not recycling properly
accosting the council an extra forty
thousand pounds a year a sum that could
be negated totally if recycling was done
properly at the depot where the rockford
district council recycling lorries role
in the waste is shared into a vast open
warehouse while the seagulls find rich
pickings the staff employed there have
the job of going through all that waste
and separate separating out the un'
recyclables just one black bag in the
recyclables rubbish can contaminate tons
more damaging the efforts of those who
take care to recycle and clean out their
items before binning them the conveyor
belts are packed
with recyclables from plastic bottles to
newspapers but other items like a girl's
necklace and hair accessories a bra and
two pairs of knickers have to be pulled
from the rest of the rubbish costing
time effort and money but this amount of
rubbish only represents just 0.08 five
percent of the total tonnage Rochford
recycles every day in total 750 tons per
month are picked up and delivered to the
waste depot and that is a lot of dirty
and smelly sorting out asked what is the
strangest thing they found in the
recycled waste the manager of the depot
said at all toys believe it or not we
once had a real live tour toys come in
on the recyclables waste but we found it
in time and it's happily been rehoused
and don't worry it wasn't from Rochford
district councils recycled waste so
here's the challenge to be the hair and
not the tour toys when it comes to
reason if all residents spring into
action now and recycle properly when our
DC officers revisit the depot in May
yeah huge drop in contaminated waste at
the moment contaminated recycled waste
it has to go into landfill is costing
the earth and residents far too much
enjoy a day of discovery in Hockley's
ancient woodlands with Rochford district
council's annual wild woods day this is
being held in hockley woods on saturday
the fourth of june 2016 between 11am and
4pm family favorites are back this
along with a host of new activities
experiences and entertainment in our
three exciting zones create and play
zone active zone and wild zone the
scouts will be taking over the wild zone
this year to create a pop-up campsite
and deliver a range of wild activities
such as axe throwing pioneering
bushcraft and tent building our create
and play zone will be featuring a
Beatrix Potter tent to celebrate the
hundred and fiftieth anniversary of her
birth entry is free to this
family-friendly event which has a focus
on green themes including recycling
sustainability and protecting the local
environment a large pop-up marketplace
will showcase local and organic produce
as well as up-cycled and recycled goods
Radio essex are back to host our stage
with charismatic presenter pool of it
and a dedicated food and picnic area
will offer a hog roast gourmet burgers
and authentic wood fired pizza oven
fresh Italian coffee and lots more
selected activities require a
three-pound wild stamp which you can
purchase on the day only one stamp is
required per person and this is valid
for a range of activities wildwoods day
is organized by Rochford District
Council leisure team and is sponsored by
fusion lifestyle and in association with
Crouch Valley Scouts for more
information about wild woods day please
contact the leisure team on 0 1 702 318
120 or email leisure at Rochford gov you
K or visit w wh the govt UK / wild woods
day rochford district matters is
designed and published by rockford
district council the telephone number
for the council is 0 1 702 546 366 and
this recording has been produced by
volunteers from Raley Rochford and
castle point talking newspaper